hi friends welcome to laser today we
have a special guest typically mataga
and silly pound bunny aisle
[Music]
and funny thank you so much for being
here thank you for having me i'm super
excited about this this is my favorite
interview of the entire year okay let's
get started my first question is what
does bitcoin mean to you
that's a great question uh i think
bitcoin ultimately just means freedom it
says that nobody can tell you what you
have to do they don't tell you when to
do it they don't tell you who you have
to do it with you're just free you can
do whatever you want you want to eat ice
cream you want to go to sleep you don't
want to go to sleep whatever you want
whenever you want that's what bitcoin
does i feel the same way
could you explain not the keys not your
coins yeah it's pretty simple it's
basically like if you want to eat a
snack if you don't have the snack you
can't eat it it's not yours well same
thing with your money now ultimately not
your keys not your coins means that you
just have to have possession and then
nobody can tell you what to do with it
it's yours that's so cool my next
question is what's this going
that's the best question that anyone's
asked me all year
i don't know how your parents let you
ask that question but that's a good one
it basically that is a term that refers
to things other than bitcoin and some
people don't like them some people like
them but it's basically just referring
to anything that's not bitcoin how do
you think a bitcoin community can
improve yeah that's a very good question
i think that myself and other people in
the bitcoin community really understand
bitcoin and have a good sense of how it
fits into the larger world you still got
to be nice to people and so every once
in a while when somebody who doesn't
like bitcoin starts talking maybe what
we can do is we can just smile at them
and say okay thanks for your opinion but
i'm going to keep doing what i'm going
to do and the nicer that you can be to
people usually eventually they start to
see the world your way i agree
thanks pop for being my guest today
absolutely thank you so much for having
me this has been one of my favorite
interviews i've ever done